si les vrais qu'on mange moins de viande
la mode est tartare ne faiblit pas d'où
l'intérêt de varier les saveurs
première arrêt Proche-Orient avec
Christelle tanielian blogueuse autrice
et cuisinière elle modernise les
recettes traditionnelles de ses
grands-mères
je pense qu'il y a autant de grand-mère
que de recettes de Queen
ça veut dire cru que B c'est le nom du
plat donc le
et à quelle occasion on le mange plutôt
pour les fêtes les célébrations les
souper du dimanche avec toute la famille
nous c'est à ce moment-là qu'on le mange
et qu'est-ce qu'il a de particulier
alors on y retrouve du boulgour fin une
viande d'agneau ou de bœuf haché très
très finement donc c'est vraiment ça le
secret on la passe 3 à 4 fois dans le
hachoir moi j'aime ça ajouter donc le
cumin du piment d'Alep la pâte de piment
fort qui va quand même aider à relever
le tartare à cette préparation on ajoute
un boulgour fin c'est important de
prendre du fin et de ne pas le cuire on
le mange cru mais rincer à l'eau un
coupe grossièrement l'oignon et on va
lâcher très finement dans le robot on
incorpore ensuite la viande
alors j'ai pris de l'agneau du Québec
aujourd'hui ce qu'on a de la chance
d'avoir du bon agneau au Québec c'est
vraiment très important qu'il soit haché
devant vos yeux si on a un choix à la
maison on pourrait le faire à la maison
et donc l'important c'est vraiment
d'avoir une pâte très très hachée une
mousseline donc qu'est-ce qu'on demande
à notre boucher concrètement on demande
de la passer 3-4 fois 5 fois ou à choix
autant qu'il peut jusqu'à obtenir de la
texture la plus fine possible
qui dit viande crue dit viande très
fraîche consommée rapidement et préparez
dans les règles d'hygiène strictes donc
on s'assure de la garder au frais déjà
le maximum de temps possible on
travaille toujours avec des mains
propres ça va de soi et on essaie de pas
la travailler trop longtemps les arômes
se dégagent déjà vraiment je sens
l'oignon
quel souvenir ça te rappelle ben moi
c'est ma famille c'est ma grand-mère
c'est les repas chez Mamie quoi c'est
c'est les cousins qu'on voit pas si
souvent finalement mais quand on se voit
c'est tout de suite vraiment la fête la
femme traditionnelle du cube B on roule
la pâte dans la paume de la main puis on
presse les doigts comme je suis un peu
rebelle moi j'aime ça créer des petites
boules dans laquelle je presse le pouce
puis que je vais placer sur l'assiette
et ça va faire un petit réceptacle à
l'huile d'olive et au garnitures qu'on
va rajouter ensuite
sur l'avenue du Parc un des rares
restaurateurs Ethiopiens à Montréal
prépare le kit faux beurre clarifié
épices et viande de boeuf composent
cette recette de tartare très prisée
tout le monde veut le code four si vous
mettez le coup de foudre sur le buffet
sur le premier qui finit 4 fois ça
dérive du verbe qui veut dire couper
donc que toi aussi prendre nommer la
viande coupée en petite morceaux
ce qui a le rend unique le coup de fouet
Ethiopien c'est le beurre et les épices
qu'on met là-dedans le beurre c'est un
beurre qui est clarifié parfumé avec des
épices vous voyez le temps on en met pas
beaucoup c'est juste pour relever
curcuma gingembre piment et Mita un
délicat mélange d'épices Ethiopienne
dans cette région tout comme au Liban le
tartare n'est pas un plat tous les jours
on te voit que trop c'est soit Noël le
soir Pâques ou bien un mariage d'un
cousin
là on le fait en petite quantité on peut
se permettre de le faire au couteau mais
quand vous êtes au restaurant avec
beaucoup de clients on le fait à la
machine
donc c'est les femmes qui coupent la
viande et c'est les hommes qui qui
discutent la plupart des temps mais les
hommes ils aident
selon la tradition éthiopienne on mange
avec les doigts en utilisant le pain
plat traditionnel le tout accompagné de
chou d'épinards et de fromage cottage
donc on prend le ingéra
en l'étendue le coup de fou si on veut
on mélange un peu du fromage et un peu
du cottage
[Musique]
avec le fromage j'adore ça c'est
tellement savoureux qu'on oublie que
c'est cru c'est bon
[Rires]
je mange pas beaucoup de viande et
encore moins cru donc c'est mon test
ultime
[Musique]
on dirait pas que c'est de la viande
crue ça pourrait être une part de
tomates ou d'aubergines
dans les versions végétariennes on
utilise des tomates ou des poivrons même
des lentilles ça pourrait être adapté
pour toi qui mange pas beaucoup de
viande je vais finir ma bouche c'est sûr
[Musique]